[Music]
[Applause]
ross tucker joins us always great to
talk to ross the host of the ross tucker
football podcast every weekday follow
him on twitter at rosstucker nfl on
social media got an issue with what hub
arkish said publicly about aaron rodgers
yeah i do dan um and i know hub i've
done some games on westwood one with him
first of all
there should be no bias
when you are making any of these votes
but let's be honest
there always is that's like the first
thing i learned in college is that
whether it's conscious or subconscious
everybody has an inherent bias i mean
hub orcish just kind of said the quiet
part out loud i know for a fact certain
guys that don't vote for guys for the
hall of fame the first year because they
don't like them because they were jerks
and they don't want them to get in on
the first ballot they don't want to get
in at all so this kind of stuff happens
a lot more than any of us realize
and i'm not going to get all up in arms
about hub arcish because to be honest
dan in my opinion he really just said
what's already been going on and already
happens for years
but has aaron rodgers been detrimental
to his team in any way
well yeah i mean he missed a game
he missed a game and it could have been
a very costly game a very important game
they probably win that game in kansas
city against the chiefs if aaron rodgers
plays i personally think that is one
knock against him for the mvp i hear a
lot people say well that chiefs game
proved how valuable he was that chiefs
game proved that he's the mvp wait a
minute wait i don't think it should help
you
or your case for the mvp
if you miss one there's only 17 of them
and you miss one think about what that
would have meant for a baseball player
or a basketball player and how your
backup does when you don't play
should not have an impact on mvp look
i'm pretty confident dan if brady didn't
play that blaine gabbard would stink up
the joint is that what we need do we
need brady sit out a game and have
gabriel go out there and play bad to see
how valuable brady is i i think it's
funny
look i think aaron rodgers has a great
argument for being mvp he probably is i
don't blame anybody that votes for him
but
brady has more touchdowns more
completions more yards they've got one
less win he's had guys banged up too
he's got guys get hurt and not play i
just think it's funny what happened is
brady got shut out by the saints
rogers hasn't had any bad games down the
stretch you know these awards turn into
like what happened the last four weeks
when i'm actually paying attention oh
brady got shot but it's like when he got
shut out by the same stand it's like
they turned the light off on the brady
mvp can't like just
he's done shut it off over let's move on
to jonathan taylor
well put i was also wondering about this
that it feels like once again this is
fluid it's like week to week aaron
rodgers might realize
how good he has it in green bay
because he might not like the front
office but the front office is very good
at drafting players they may not have
drafted the right player with jordan
love
but you play the bears the lions and the
vikings
you have six games against them
why would you want to leave that like
you want to go to denver uh whatever it
is i i keep coming back to green bay
still has
offensive line the defense is you know
one of the top five you're getting star
players back you got devonta adams there
what is it that he's going to that's
going to be so much better than green
bay
yeah i think a lot of things have
happened and and will happen over the
next few weeks that will affect his
mindset there
i think the roethlisberger send-off
had an impact on him i mean how could it
not right i think that is something that
he will factor in
i think the fact that meaning meaning
the embracement of the fans and that cal
ripken victory lap is that that's what
you mean it'll have an impact on rogers
yeah i mean i think it would be
it would be a little bit unnatural to
look at that and not think i would want
that
like i mean i was obviously a seven year
journeyman o lyman so but i watched that
and been like man that must be awesome
like that must be really really cool
and you know if you leave to go to
another team
you never really get that
i do think he realizes how good the team
is in green bay it does appear
as if you know he just wanted to say
he just wanted to say and when they went
out and got randall cobb and some of the
things they've done
there they've given him that say so he's
kind of got what he wanted that said
then
if they lose in the playoffs again
and it's a special teams issue or
defense
maybe he'll still want to leave what i
find interesting
is the jordan love component of it
because a lot of people always thought
that this would be the off season that
the packers trade aaron rodgers but if
he wins the mvp again or maybe they win
the super bowl they can't trade him i
mean they're not going to want to trade
him it might be time for jordan love to
go somewhere else
antonio brown situation
i said you know what everybody got what
they deserved here that they did win a
super bowl you were playing with fire
he's burnt down buildings and three
other stops here and he's doing the same
thing in tampa bay now i have to look at
both sides as much as i love bruce
arians i think bruce is being
disingenuous when he says he didn't know
about antonio brown's ankle injury the
guy was limited in practice didn't
practice a couple of days he was
questionable for the game
and i don't know if he checked out of
that game there was a moment where i
thought brady walking down the bench
and you could see where antonio brown
had his arms up on the bench and it
looked like he had basically checked out
of the game before
he uh
kind of lit the the fuse here so
i i don't know how this plays out he
said that he was told that you know hey
you got to get shot up with a dangerous
drug here i don't think you spend a
decade in the nfl and you don't know
about toradol
but
is antonio do you think he has
a case here against the tampa bay
buccaneers that he can get paid get
released and maybe play with somebody
else
well that's certainly what he's trying
to do um i got a bunch of thoughts on
this dan you know first of all
one of his main problems
is
antonio brown's lost the benefit of the
doubt yeah right i mean there have been
so many things over the last three years
that even with these text messages he's
sending out even if he's a hundred
percent right in this situation
i think he'll have a tough time in the
court of public opinion
because of a couple of different things
number one
everything that's happened up until this
point but also dan i've seen guys with
bad ankles i've seen guys with ankle
sprains whatever
they're not exiting like he exited that
game
they're not jumping up and down in the
end zone like like if you have an ankle
injury you're that that ankle is
bothering you and you're limping on it
he didn't show any limp or anything in
the end zone which i think also
hurts his cause and here's the last
thing which i think is the most
important
i played for five teams dan
there are some guys
who
don't play
or try not to play because of injury
but it's really more mental than
physical if that makes sense like yeah
they have an injury
but
what's preventing them from actually
going out there
is what they're thinking in their head
about the injury
as opposed to the physical malady itself
i had a guy one time i'm not going to
embarrass him but this guy
was a high pick he would do whatever it
took to try to not play in the game i
mean there were times where i can
remember the head coach
flipping out on the orthopedic surgeon
because all of a sudden the guy didn't
wasn't going to play that day and he was
supposed to he'd practice that week i
remember one time we were playing we
were playing in san francisco and they
did fireworks before the game
and we're all standing there and they
were it's foggy it was candlestick
there's a little bit of fog there all of
a sudden we're about to go out there dan
for the first series and this same guy
is like oh
oh my eyes my eyes the fireworks got in
my eyes like i can't play
i'm not i swear to god and the trainers
gave him his helmet they left they they
helped him off the bench and they're
like you're fine go out there you're fi
like they like pushed him out there like
he he did not want to i mean we were all
we were laughing but that that was him
so i think how we can balance
aryan side and antonio brown's side is
that
he did have an ankle issue by the way
everybody playing at this point in the
season has an issue everybody has at
least one thing bothering them i can
assure you otherwise what have you been
doing the whole time
and i think aryans
thought it was antonio brown mentally
not going back out there
as opposed to because of the ankle and i
think with antonio brown's history i can
totally understand
why aryans felt that way
talking to ross tucker the host of the
ross tucker football podcast he's going
to take part in the national
championship game between montana state
and north dakota state i love that and
that will be noon on saturday on
westwood 1. he's got the chargers
raiders game on sunday night also on
westwood one paulie how many times did
ross tucker play in san francisco well
you'd think a lot with the long career
uh i got yours one road game in san
francisco ross in 2004 with the buffalo
bills
was on the team for washington in 2002
when we played out there as well but i
don't think i think that was the first
game of my career i was inactive however
you don't know whether or not that was
the firework game or not so the the i
team
on it okay can we guess the player who
didn't want to play because he had smoke
in his eyes
um look you could probably google it
i don't know i don't know if that
story's ever been told but it was
it was hilarious paulie can you guess is
the i team on this the player is it a a
good player a really good player or a
little bit he was a high pick ross said
he was a high draft pick
there's names like takeo spikes
no no it's a wide receiver oh
a wide receiver is that no i didn't say
it was a wide receiver well you didn't
no okay no it's not eric molds
you guys are so good at this you guys
always try to get i don't look i don't
want to embarrass the guy he hasn't
played for a while he was a nice guy uh
he was really into video games
i'm sure he's got a great life now
i don't i don't want to embarrass him
any further i probably talked about him
on other shows before what what has what
does playing video games have to do with
this he's a good guy plays video games
um
he was more intense
about playing video games in the players
lounge
that he was on the field and that is a
fact okay he got more animated
playing halo
in the players lounge than he ever did
on the field ever oh that's so good i
like how you don't want to embarrass the
guy talk about him but now you keep
adding more layers to this paulie it
wasn't lee evans was it
i'm not saying
i'm not saying i'm not saying because it
just does and by the way it's better
it's like the whole franco harris
immaculate reception yeah
not quite the same
not not quite
but it'll make the story go on longer
and you guys will spend more time trying
to figure out who it is if i don't tell
you who it is all right chargers raiders
final game of the regular season and
that will come down to what in this game
yeah i think it'll come down to the last
drive and i got to be honest i i kind of
give the
the benefit of the doubt there to the
raiders you know the raiders have won i
gotta check my notes they've won two or
three overtime games this year
derek carr has been very clutch
in those moments late in games we saw
that again against the colts on sunday
herbert has had an unbelievable year you
know setting franchise records with
touchdown passes
but i guess i kind of feel like even
though herbert's more talented
i kind of feel like derek carr
is more clutch or at least he has been
this year if it comes down to a you know
whoever has the ball last i think it
will i think the raiders i'm actually
surprised that they are underdogs at
home in this game
you've been on the derek carr bandwagon
though for a while haven't you
so impressed by him this year you know
not only dan
the way he's kept that team afloat
after the gruden thing and the henry
ruggs thing and arnett
you know they this team could have
collapsed so many times and it felt like
derek carr
has willed them
to this point but if you remember after
the henry ruggs uh terrible terrible
accident i don't know if you guys talked
about it but to hear derek carr say you
know i'm going to love henry ruggs right
now
because somebody needs to after he
obviously did
a horrible hor i'm just really impressed
by derek carr as a human being i never
even met him i saw him before the
cowboys game i didn't say anything to
him i don't think i've ever met him i'm
very impressed from afar
by the way he carries himself
yeah
but what is it what's he missing that he
he kind of gets lumped in the kirk
cousins category
yeah it's funny because i think he's a
top ten quarterback i think he's eight
nine or ten
i think uh when you are a guy that
number one
doesn't have any wow physical traits
so he does not josh allen or herbert's
arm or stafford's arm doesn't have any
wow physical traits
and has not had post-season success that
is the double whammy that when when you
have those two things
that you're always going to have your
group of people that say he sucks man
he's like kirk causes he sucks they're a
car he sucks like unless you do things
that wow them
or you have playoff success
you're gonna be now listen there's 20
teams in the nfl that would take derek
carr as their quarterback there's 15
that would take kirk cousins but yet
those guys still get a lot of the ire
from fans because of exactly what i just
mentioned great to talk to you safe
travels ross as always thank you for
joining us
oh my eyes
[Laughter]
that's ross tucker host of the ross
tucker football podcast so he's on the
call for the fcs national title game
westwood one at noon montana state north
dakota state i'll be watching that and
on the call for the chargers raiders
game and that's also sunday night on
westwood what